hi everybody welcome to the second of
the new q and a's uh
we started them up again in 2021 and i'm
pulling
questions off online sources at the
moment think spot
in part uh other sources as well like
instagram
i've got about 15 lined up for today
i'll start with something that's
somewhat of a softball to warm myself up
a bit thank you for tuning in and i hope
that these
are useful to you can i read beyond
order if i did not read 12 rules for
life
the answer to that is yes i wrote the
books to
stand on their own i think they
complement each other
if i had to recommend a preferred order
of reading i would say
read the first one first 12 rules for
life first and the second one beyond
order second
but it's not necessary um if you read
beyond order first and twelve rules for
sec
second or if you just read one of them
that'll work out fine too
i wanted the books to stand alone so
they're not dependent on one another
for those of you who don't know 12 rules
for life concentrates more on problems
that are associated with an excess of
uncertainty and anxiety
chaos and beyond order concentrates on
problems that are more associated with
an excess of order
stultification and boredom and and
entrapment and
and tyranny that sort of thing and so
they make a match
set given that i view life i suppose
from a narrative perspective as
the battle between good and evil it's a
moral battle morality because we have to
make choices about how to act and how to
perceive
value predicated choices so that puts us
into the domain of
morality so we play out the battle
between good and evil on a background of
order
and chaos certainty and uncertainty or
explored territory versus unexplored
territory or culture
versus nature those are some of the
antithesis
described in particular in chapter 11 of
the second book beyond order so
that's the answer to that question can i
explain
what i mean by postmodern neo-marxism
well i hope i can explain it uh since
i've been talking about it it's not that
easy to explain because a lot of these
terms
terms like existentialism phenomenology
modernism post-modernism they're they're
they
they applied to very large domains of
thought and it's not
always easy to settle on a definition
um but we'll give it a shot so
hypothetically
postmodernism is a reaction to modernism
a critical reaction to modernism
modernism if you think about it in the
enlightenment sense is predicated on the
idea that
the individual is paramount is the
proper
unit of analysis is a fundamental
reality
is a rational being although also
emotional nature
is capable of independent speech and
thought
can uh act rationally and think
rationally and so that would mean
way arguments according to their
applicability
uh logic uh coherence
um evidence
change perception and action as a
consequence
be reasoned with um
be validly attributed and independent
sovereignty free will
that's all part of the modernist
set of presuppositions post-modernists
are hypothetically skeptical of all
grand narratives
that might include all religious
narratives might include
the claim that there's such thing as a
universal hero mythology for example
um and might aim at criticizing the
grand
enlightenment narrative um
so post-modernism has often been
described as skepticism about grand
narratives
now the problem with that as far as i'm
concerned is that
i don't really see the skepticism i see
skepticism about
some grand narratives so perhaps there's
skepticism about the enlightenment
and the modernist view humanist
modernist
and religious view of the individual but
what i saw happening and see happening
still is that
although the formal claim is made that
skepticism about grand narratives is
paramount
what happens in practice and also
in theory is that a new kind of
narrative
is ushered in and it's one that appears
to me to be
a not very well disguised derivative of
marxism
and the marxist claim essentially is
that or one of the marxist claims
essentially is that
history is best viewed as the economic
battleground
between oppressor and oppressed between
exploiter and exploited between
bourgeoisie and proletariat uh between
owners and workers
and that that's there's no more
important
phenomena at the individual and group
level than that conflict
um although there is a tremendous
difference between
people in terms of status i don't
believe that that's a particularly
useful way of
interpreting the world and i think that
the evidence that interpreting the world
in that manner can
lead to devastating consequences is
overwhelming
there are no successful marxist
governments there are no successful
governments that rely essentially on
central planning and that are informed
by marxist theory there are catastrophic
failures that are often genocidal now
what's happened with the postmodernists
is that
many of them were technically speaking
marxists
to begin with especially the french
intellectuals people like foucault and
darada
were card-carrying marxists often or
certainly
sympathetic to marxist claims back in
the 1960s
and when it became evident to everyone
that
the application of marxism almost
inevitably resulted in
tyranny and genocide
it became no longer intellectually
credible to
promote those ideas
as an intellectual not that that
necessarily stopped everybody from doing
so
well what seemed to happen what happened
as far as i can tell is that
the idea of economic conflict was
replaced by the idea of
power that that
the most important element of an
individual
isn't their individual identity but the
group that they belong to
the racial group the ethnic group that
the gender um the sex
the sexual preference doesn't matter
some element of group identity
and that the world is best construed as
a
battle for power between
these different groups and i don't see
that there's really much difference
between the proposition that
history was driven by economic conflict
between the oppressor and the
oppressed and the claim that history is
driven by
power relationships between the
oppressor and the oppressed
and i also failed to see how that's not
a grand narrative
the idea that and i also i should also
point out that i believe
that the idea is absolutely preposterous
not only is it wrong
the idea that social institutions are
essentially
predicated on power so that if you are
striving for power you're more likely to
succeed in a given
functional social institution um i don't
believe that there's any evidence that
that's the case and plenty of
evidence to the contrary because the
arbitrary expression of power
is actually not a very effective means
of attaining
status and authority it's certainly a
terrible means of attaining competence
so
the degree to which our social
institutions are predicated on
actual competence the ability to solve
problems that we all regard as
necessary problems to solve
striving for power is no means to attain
competence and to the degree that our
institutions are based on competence
they don't select for power and people
who use
power arbitrarily to force other people
to do their will
are not likely to run stable
institutions they're likely to be
overthrown by their underlings often in
not very pleasant manner and that's true
not only for human beings but also for
for animals such as our nearest cousins
say chimpanzees
with the evidence has become quite clear
from the work of primatologists such as
franz dewal that
tyrannical chimps can attain
the pinnacle of power in a chimp given
chimp hierarchy for
a short period of time but tend um
differentially to be torn to shreds by
a couple of junior interlopers who band
together
and tired sick and tired of the tyranny
it's not a stable means of of of
generating social interaction and
the chimps that dewall has studied who
managed to maintain power
or authority or position let's say over
some reasonable period of time
tend to be more reciprocal and more
interactive than their subordinate peers
they have to spend a lot of time
maintaining relationships rather than
lording it over others and
it's also the case that none of the
successful people i've ever met
regardless of the enterprise that they
happen to be
involved in entrepreneurial managerial
administrative
um or academic scientific
or in creative domains that are more
entrepreneurial
the people i've met that were most
successful
and and perhaps also most satisfied by
their success
were people who constantly went out of
their way
to be of aid to their superiors their
peers and their
subordinates and the idea that
it's the desire for power
that drives all of us forward
is um well as i said it's not a credible
idea scientifically
uh partly because the expression of
aggression
which has to be related to the
expression of power if power is to mean
anything so it has to be
i'll use my capacity for aggression
to force you to do something that you
wouldn't do voluntarily that's a
reasonable definition of the expression
of power
it's failures by and large who turn to
aggression
to mediate their social interactions and
people become less aggressive as they're
socialized
not more aggressive and chronically
aggressive children adolescent
and adults tend to be alienated isolated
friendless family-less and
uh criminal slash incarcerated it's not
a good strategy
and so post-modernism shouldn't be
allied with marxism because
post-modernism is hypothetically
skepticism about
the applicability of grand narratives
and then the assumption that grand
narratives but
then the assumption comes in that the
grand narratives
were only stories told by people
attempting to justify their
um arbitrary grip on the levers of
power let's say and that leads us into
the entire proposition that our social
institutions
and our ambitions are essentially
predicated on the desire for power and
as i said that appears to me to be
not only wrong but anti-true
and i've been thinking about the idea of
anti-truth lately i mean
you know if you lie the best way to lie
is to almost tell the truth
and so you know it's false but it's
close to the truth so maybe you can get
away with it but there are forms of
discourse let's say or or there
are theoretical propositions that are so
opposite to reality that they're not
just
lies they they are the opposite of
the case and i truly believe that our
functional social institutions are held
together
by productive reciprocity they
degenerate when they degenerate they
degenerate
they can degenerate into a tyranny
that's predicated on power
but the fact that degenerate
institutions are predicated on power
is only an indication that they're
degenerate it's no indication at all
that that's the central tendency
of our most fundamental social
institutions imagine you believe that
well
imagine that you believe that it's power
well then you're going to be inclined to
exercise
power insofar as you wish to be
successful and so maybe that's a way of
justifying your own power drive
um but if you're guilty about that
because you think that
the arbitrary expression of power is
immoral and
perhaps you should think that then
you're going to view your own
ambitions and certainly the ambitions of
others with the tremendous skepticism
and how are you going to move forward
with any confidence in your life
if you believe that your own ambitions
to succeed
are predicated on nothing but the
arbitrary expression of power and so i
think it's also psychologically
devastating
so now post there's another element of
post-modernism that we should discuss
too and
that's the idea that and again these are
vague ideas
that
there's how would how would we put it
there's also criticisms of the idea of
objective truth
and so classically speaking we would
draw a distinction between
what's real in the world as such
independent of our interpretation
and our interpretation there are lines
of post-modernist thinking and these are
particularly associated with dereda that
appear to imply
although it's difficult to pin down that
everything is interpretation
and that's part of the skepticism
everything's interpretation but then
what that leads the practitioners of
those interpretive theories
uh to conclude is well back to power
because that's they sneak this grand
narrative back in that way and
as far as i'm concerned that's just a
new justification for
old marxist presuppositions so
i hope that's clear it probably isn't
but
it's as good as i can do at the moment
hi jp given your oft repeated messages
about the dangers of ideology what
advice do you have for your fans who may
view
your own teachings with such dogma
i guess who may view your own teachings
with such
well i'll just read the question given
your oft repeated message about the
dangers of ideology what advice do you
have for your fans
who may view your own teachings with
such regard that those ideas become an
ideology themselves
lots of love from a 98th percentile
orderly
uk based engineer well
the first thing i would say is that
whenever
a developing mind encounters
a comprehensive set of novel ideas
there is the initial danger of sliding
into
uncritical acceptance of those ideas and
that can happen
whenever you read anyone who's thought
through things with some degree of
thoroughness so i fell into nietzsche i
fell into
dostoyevsky i fell into jung i fell into
freud i fell into rogers
the latter are all clinicians when i
teach my personality course when i
taught my personality course at harvard
and u of t
i would present each thinker in the
strongest possible terms and
even though they didn't always agree
that there was a central element of
agreement but certainly plenty of
disagreement
and that was somewhat disconcerting to
the students because they would identify
with one thinker and then we'd go on to
another and they'd identify with them
and then we'd go on to another and
and so on but i i think that's okay as
long as you come out the other end and
you tend to
and so when you encounter a new set of
ideas you do tend to
adopt them somewhat dogmatically to
begin with as you're puzzling through
them
and then later with more development and
more reading
you kind of come back to yourself and so
i think that's part of the developmental
course of
expanding your philosophical or
psychological knowledge
um i do warn against oversimplified
thinking
particularly in chapter six of beyond
order which is
called abandoned ideology and that's a
method uh it's actually a discourse on
methodology of thought you know
what i warn against primarily there are
low resolution
answers to low resolution questions what
should we do about
the planet's ecology that's just not a
very good question it's way too vague
how should we restructure our economic
system
well it's too global and vague those
those questions
don't lead to productive answers because
they're ill-formed
how do we make people less aggressive
that's another
category another question of that type
you have to differentiate the questions
so
to a to a very high degree before you
can before you can be reasonably sure
that your conceptualization is
productive and not dangerous and so that
you have some
shot at perhaps answering the question
in part
so with regards to aggression for
example maybe you're concerned about
interpersonal aggression aggression
between people you might be able to say
how could we reduce the incidence of
physical aggression kicking biting and
hitting for example
among six-year-old boys in a given
geographical locale
a much more specific sort of question so
i would encourage people to think in
detail and not to accept
blanket ideological answers you do that
in proportion to your ignorance of the
field like we
all of us want to have a complete map of
the world but
we lack differentiated knowledge of many
many things and so when an ideology
comes along that purports
to provide all the answers to even
questions that we haven't yet asked were
likely to be to welcome it because it
fills in the gaps in our map
but you have to be careful of confusing
that with genuine
knowledge um
and then and and you have to strive
towards genuine knowledge
so i would say for people who believe
perhaps that they've fallen too deeply
under the sway of my ideas the best
antidote to that would be to read other
people
i have a reading list online at
jordanbpeterson.com under books there's
a list of recommended books there which
were books that i found particularly
influential
you know so maybe that would just cement
the dogma but i don't think it would
and so broader reading is is advised and
and writing as well for that matter if
you really want to learn to think
in in a revelatory manner creative
manner and also in a
critical manner writing and editing is
an extremely useful thing to do so but
i'll reiterate you know when you first
encounter a set of philosophical ideas
especially if you're not
haven't been inclined to think
philosophically that much in the past
you're very much likely to come under
the powerful sway of the first
trained mind that you encounter but
well don't stop there you know there's
lots of other people to read
so
i guess the other thing i would
recommend is and i outlined this in
chapter 12 although it's a very strong
theme in my first book maps of meaning
i viewed the teaching that i did
and the writing especially with maps of
meaning as
an antidote to ideology and
because i came you know it's not easy to
differentiate
ideology from belief or ideology from
religion for that matter so what's the
difference between ideology and
religious belief or belief per se
my sense was that an ideology not only
provides a very low resolution
representation of the world but
it also tends to only tell part of the
story
now so then you might ask well what's
the whole story
and that's a very complicated question
but my answer to that
and this is a consequence of reading
deeply into the clinical
literature my hypothesis about that
was something that was essentially it
turned out being essentially akin to
freud
now freud produced a very balanced
picture of the
psyche which is part of the reason
freud's thinking was so influential and
part of the reason why
his thinking still saturates our
thinking even though we think we've
dispensed with freud actually what we've
done is incorporated
the most brilliant insights of freud so
deeply that we think of them as
presuppositions now obvious like that we
have an ego
everyone knows what the id is or
virtually everyone or certainly believes
that we're driven by
fundamentally you know unconscious and
biological drives
that's a very freudian idea and that
that there is some
superego you know the effect of society
upon us or at least some concept that's
akin to that
we've we've taken a lot of freud's ideas
but freud was very balanced
because he talked about the id so you
could think about that as
nature within it's the natural world
within
it was a positive element and a negative
element it was the source of all energy
but also
it was blind in its motivational demands
let's say
blind and wild in its motivational
demands unruly and dangerous as a force
although completely necessary and then
the ego
well the ego was had a positive element
and a negative element as well so
and then the super egos that's society
all things considered that's the
patriarchy in
in from the freudian perspective it can
be over weaning and tyrannical so it can
go too far and be negative but it's also
a positive force because it counter
balances
the blind selfish
impulsive narrow drives of the id
and make social organization possible
so freud has a three-tier
view of psychological reality and each
element
has a positive and negative uh
pole and to me that indicates a balanced
theory
um i believe that an intact religion
tends to produce a balanced
representation of that sort and what
ideology
ideologies do is parasitize that
fundamental narrative and so
i can outline two ideologies
so i would say that the the narrative
that drove the settling of
the united states in particular the
frontier myth that's a
ideology so it's positive individual
that's the
you know forthright pioneer boldly going
where no one has gone before
because a positive view of civilization
and society because
along with the pioneering spirit comes
the civilization
that's imposed on well then there's
nature
negative it needs civilizing it's a wild
force and the positive
individual bringing benevolent culture
to this savage
world that's the frontier myth and it's
very motivating and it's true
because that's a story that can be acted
out but it's incomplete and
i believe that that was compensated for
that incompleteness was compensated for
that this started to happen in the early
in the late
1800s with the rise of the conservation
ethic but also
really manifested itself in the 1960s
with the environmentalist
ideology and i'm not saying that there
is no
valid environmentalist claims that
that's different i
issue but there's a narrative the
individual is a power hungry despoiler
society is fundamentally rapacious
greedy and devouring and mother nature
is being
in here all her innocence raped
continually
so and you see that's exactly the
opposite of the frontier myth
wherever it lacked so the frontier myth
had a negative
view of nature although it could be
fertile but only
you know if social if so if
brought under the sway of the proper
social
processes civilization agricultural of
that
it had to be tamed nature was wild while
the environmental nature is
everything beautiful in and of itself
the benevolence of of mother nature
and society on the frontier myth side is
a civilizing forest and on the
environmentalists side is a despoiling
force and the individual is
a hero in the um
frontier myth but a villain essentially
a villain
a selfish greedy grasping devouring
villain on the environmentalist front
now if you put both of those together
you get a whole you get the whole story
now of course it's rife with paradoxes
and that's
problematic people don't like that but
it's much more comprehensive
and so i've suggested to people that
you know if you only have a negative
view of the patriarchy for example
well where's the positive element and if
you only have a positive view of nature
well
you know what about cancer and guinea
worms i think they're called giddy worms
um they're a kind of parasitic worm that
whose nature i don't want to go into but
aren't pleasant and have thankfully been
eradicated
um and then with regard to the
individual too is like well there should
be polarity there
um and i think in a well-functioning
religious system
provides you with a polarized view of
all these different levels of reality
individual social and natural and
ideologies fragment that and so they
gain their power by
writing like parasites on underlying
religious
reality essentially uh religious
narrative
that's necessary to orient you properly
in the world
functionally in the world and and
functionally both with regard to
yourself
functionally with regard to yourself
nature and society
so um well
that's the answer to that question hi dr
peterson i have a 12 year old sister
who's recently been really interested in
starting dressing as a boy
even changing her hair and cutting it
very short i'm sure she is in an
exploratory phase but i'm a little
worried
should i or my parents intervene or let
her just explore now that she's young
lovely to have you back dr peterson uh
well thank you for that
um look let me tell you a story about my
son
uh when he was little three two maybe
even
two probably really little his sister
who was a year
and a half older had a bunch of female
friends obviously and
um they used to play dress up in the
basement and they'd spend
a fair bit of time dressing julian up in
like as a fairy or as a princess and
um you know i kind of cast my eyes
upward on that and my eyebrows and
but then i thought about it for a couple
of minutes and i thought well
look what's going on here well
julian is engaged in this game
and he's having a good time and so you
know he was
i trusted his instincts as a small child
you know to the degree that you can
trust a small child's instincts because
they go astray too but
you know he seemed to be a well-adjusted
kid and he was playing
and what do you do when you play well
you experiment with different
roles with different identities that's
what especially fantasy play that's what
fantasy play is
so let's say that you're a little boy
and you want to understand
little girls well you're not gonna think
them through i mean
jesus even adult males can't think adult
females through
i mean they're caught we're very
complicated and
um thinking about it
isn't necessarily going to get you very
far it's like thinking about dancing
isn't going to make you into a good
dancer
and so what julian was doing in some
sense was more akin to dancing than to
thinking
he was playing at what it meant to be
female so he was using him
his own body his own um
being to act out what was
feminine and the girls were playing with
that too
you know they they were trying to assess
the difference between male and female
and
and how those might inter relate and
that's why they were fascinated with
that kind of dress up play so i just let
it
go let it happen and that was the right
decision because i realized that
had i interfered with it i would have
been saying to him
the feminine the nature of the feminine
is such
that it presents such a danger to what
is masculine
or what is young that it can't even be
played with in fantasy
and that's definitely the wrong message
and so you know he dressed up like a
print let them dress him up as a
princess and enjoy the door as a fairy
and
played it out and that was all fine and
you know he he did now how much this had
to do with that play i have no idea but
he
grew up to be you know a very diplomatic
and
understanding sort of person and
although he's tough as a boot and so
it worked out fine now with regards to
your 12 year old sister
look there's a huge range of gender
experimentation and gender
expression among young people and i
would say that your instincts that this
is an exploratory phase
are accurate and that you should leave
it be however i would also say that you
should be there
and watch and talk because things are so
unsettled now in relationship to gender
identity
that what could easily just be laudable
exploratory play or the exploration of
the boundaries of gender identity could
easily be transformed into
assertions by ideologically adult
uh interlocutors that this is
indication that your sister is in fact
male
and and that's a that would be a
consequence of falling prey to the very
stereotypes that
are hypothetically under attack the fact
that this girl
woman to be is feeling
urges to toy with a masculine self
presentation
is no indication that is no necessary
indication that at some level she
desires
to be a man it's a form of play and
it should or a form of fashion which is
also a form of play for that matter
and so i think your best bet is to
say to her implicitly and explicitly
you'd say it implicitly by leaving it
alone to some degree but even explicitly
to say look if you want to
play around the boundaries of
identification as male or female
go right ahead but don't mistake
don't prematurely mistake your interest
in the manner in which the other
sex presents itself as
some indication that there's something
flawed about your own
or questionable about your own identity
as a female it's no it's not evidence
for that
and so play but don't assume that the
play is
manifesting itself because there's some
necessarily hidden reality that has to
be brought to the surface
and i think that is a real danger in in
the political landscape that we have set
up right now
so it's play and fair enough
so you know you see this
there's all sorts of play in in terms of
gender representation in the 1970s in in
the rock and roll
world there's a whole subset of glam
rock which was
um men and theatrical men
adopting makeup and and and
high heels platform shoes tight clothes
long hair all elements of femininity
essentially
uh kind of a dramatic femininity they
were still
men it was part of play and
entertainment and
and uh drama and that's fine
you don't the drama doesn't have to take
on a physiological reality
you know at that point you have to
wonder if it's going a bit too far
that that should be the first
presumption is that it's gone a bit too
far at that point
so
so i'd say lever b
encourage her for that matter but keep
an eye on her you know
and and don't let her fall prey to
any foolish advice and don't let her get
too confused
as a consequence of her exploration in
all probability i mean this is the
general
life course even children who have
gender dysphoria you know so
who are unhappy with their current sex
um the data indicate that the vast
majority of them settle into identity
with their physiological form
and their psychobiological form for that
matter
by the time they're 18. so and there's a
tremendous
wide tremendously wide range of
femininity to masculinity within women
and a tremendously wide range of
femininity
to masculinity within men too so what
constitutes
normal is a pretty broad category and
so probably don't worry about it
it's it's and there might even be some
rebellion in it and that's not
necessarily a bad thing in teenagers as
well they have to push back
in some ways so
yeah i hope you're doing well dr jordan
peterson well thank you for that
thanks for all your work question i've
noticed in myself that i'm insensitive
and i have a hard time empathizing with
others losses
everyone was in shock and grief crying
except me for example when my uncle
mid 50 died in an accident a few weeks
ago
sorry to hear that and i noticed now
many times in the past that i'm callous
and indifferent
to human suffering or feelings is it
something important to think about and
reconcile or perhaps some people are
just born that way
if they are how can i develop myself
well
i don't know because i don't know you
but so i have to give a generic answer
i would first of all caution you against
taking this answer too personally
because i don't know who you are
and i need to know the details but i can
answer it generically to some degree
so the first thing i'd like to point out
is that despite your claims to be
callous and indifferent
you were polite enough to open this
question with a query
or comment on my well-being i hope you
were doing well dr jordan peterson so
even if you didn't feel that hope
deeply you were polite enough to
to utter it and politeness is an
aspect technically speaking politeness
is an aspect
of trait agreeableness which is the
empathy
dimension so there's five cardinal
personality dimensions
extroversion sociability positive
emotion gregariousness
extroverts love to be in groups they
like to entertain they like to be the
center of attention
they're they're energetic active and
manifest a lot of positive emotion
they're verbal as well
um introverts they're quiet they tend to
keep to themselves they'd rather have
one-on-one interactions with people
um i think introverts prefer nature and
extroverts prefer
the human social world but the evidence
for the introverted
preference for nature is weaker but it's
it's something that i've noticed
for what it's worth neuroticism that's
the negative emotion
uh dimension some people experience much
higher
levels of negative emotion per unit of
negative experience
than others that might be relevant to
you and we'll get back to that
agreeableness which is the empathy
dimension women are higher in
agreeableness they're higher in
neuroticism as well
quite substantially in both cases
although populations of men and women
overlap more than they differ
agreeableness is the empathy dimension
it's composed of
compassion and politeness and you're
describing yourself as relatively low
perhaps relatively low in compassion
that's a more masculine
mode of being and um in its extreme it
can produce callousness and
insensitivity to the point where
the best personality predictor of
criminal
predatory behavior antisocial behavior
is low agreeableness
but it has to be pretty damn low and it
has to be combined with other
negative attributes before that's a
problem because disagreeable people
are also very tough-minded skeptical
hard to push around
ambitious forthright um
and and um well they're good people to
have on your side they'll tell you bad
news when they need to
um so it's in and of itself it's not
necessarily a detrimental trait so we'd
have to look at your entire personality
okay that the fourth dimension is
conscientiousness that's orderliness and
industriousness and the fifth dimension
is openness to experience which is
essentially
creativity and intelligence some amalgam
of that
so the first thing we'd have to figure
out is why
you are less emotional
than other people now there's two likely
possible reasons so
the first thing i would recommend for
you is that you go to this website that
my colleagues and i built called
understandmyself.com
understandmyself.com you can do a good
personality test there
that'll give you the five factors and
break each of them down into their two
aspects
now what i would predict in your case is
that
you're relatively low in agreeableness
particularly compassion
and you may also be relatively low in
neuroticism which means that you're just
not that prone to negative emotion
and so the combination of those two
which is very masculine by the way
low neuroticism and low agreeableness
that's masculine personality
configuration
means that you don't feel negative
emotion as much as other people might so
you'd be much less likely to cry for
example even
under conditions that might evoke grief
in other people
and you're not as empathetic you don't
feel other
people's feelings as intensely as
someone who's highly empathetic
and that's possible you could be low in
agreeableness and low in
neuroticism i wouldn't despair if i was
you because that doesn't doom you to a
life of callousness
let's think about other personality
configurations
that might be relevant to you if you're
extroverted
and low in agreeableness you tend to be
narcissistic because
an extroverted person likes to dominate
the social
circumstance and if they're disagreeable
as well then they don't really care
about their impact on other people and
so extroversion
high extroversion plus low agreeableness
can lead to narcissism and
you have to watch that because if you're
narcissistic then
you really are the star all for yourself
and that's actually just not a very good
way of negotiating the world
people will turn off to you after some
time because they'll discover that
you're not
reciprocal enough in your interactions
you're not generous enough
it might be helpful if you were high in
conscientiousness
let's say because if agreeableness helps
make someone social
one of the things that helps make them
socially acceptable reciprocal
altruistic
willing to do favors for other people
generous and so forth
conscientiousness also aids in that
conscientious people are
likely to keep their word they have
integrity they they're honest
they'll they'll make and keep
verbal contracts and so if you're low in
agreeableness but high in
conscientiousness people can still trust
you even though you're a hard ass
you know fundamentally you're honest and
so you'll do what you say you'll do if
you're high in conscientiousness
now if you're low in conscientiousness
and low in agreeableness
well that's that can start to be trouble
because
then you you're not likely to work that
hard and you're likely to take advantage
of others and so
that starts to get into more serious
personality configuration problem
now if you're high in neuroticism
and low in agreeableness that can also
be problematic that's
hallmark of personality disorder not all
personality disorders but some of them
because you're you experience a
tremendous amount of distress
and you'll use that as a weapon because
you don't really care about
your impact on other people and so that
can be a problem
but
i wouldn't presume
on the basis of what you've told me that
you're in trouble
now if you are genuinely extremely low
in
in compassion for example so take this
personality test and find out and
extremely low would be let's say
under fifth percentile and even then
it's
you're one in 20 so that's not that bad
you know it's or no
not that extreme i don't mean bad if
you're at the
first percentile well you know that's
starting to get
into genuine extreme if you're really
low in compassion
you might and this would work especially
well if you were high in
conscientiousness
but it might work anyways you might try
as an
exercise to regularly and routinely
think of something that you could do for
other people and
do it like you might have to do that
coldly and cognitively in some sense
instead of emotionally
and nicely but i suspect that that would
help expand your personality so you
could still have the advantages of being
disagreeable being hard to take
advantage of for example
but you could learn the advantages of
generosity and reciprocity
and so that's
about the best i can do with that so
probably you're low in agreeableness and
low in negative emotion and
probably not too low in each so
you know do the personality test and
find out and if you are really low in
agreeableness then think perhaps
of making a conscious plan to be
more reciprocal to do things for other
people to learn how to do that as a
skill
that would likely serve you well if
you're really low in negative emotion
neuroticism
i wouldn't worry about that too much
unless you're really high in
extroversion because that might mean
that you're
likely to take more risks than you
should because you get enthusiastic and
carried away and you're not afraid even
when you should be
so that's that pretty much
how to understand god is love
you talk about god as the ultimate judge
and focus on accountability slash living
as if god exists
but how to love god is it a feeling like
loving a person
can love balance out the crushing
responsibility
this is a hard question i'm going to
take it apart in a couple of ways
this is my understanding so it isn't how
to understand god is love because i
can't answer that question but i can
i can i can provide some information
about how i might understand what that
means
well the first thing is is that i think
that you
you have to make a decision in your life
and this is
this is a decision and i would say that
it's a voluntary element of faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's
more like you decide to stake your life
on this like you know if you decide to
get married to someone
you don't really do it on the basis of
the evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you
do it you decide that you're going to
make a happy life with this person
and that it's worth the risk so you you
get married as an expression of
faith okay and and so faith doesn't
mean believing things that no one with
any sense would believe
faith sometimes means putting a stake in
the sand and saying
here's where i stand in some sense
regardless and you do that when you get
married you do that maybe when you
you know pledge allegiance to a friend
you have a best friend and you want to
maintain that friendship
as long as you possibly can it's it's
it's a decision of faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to
university because you could have done
something else right but you chose that
so that's where you put your faith
and like i said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe
okay so back to god is love well i'm
going to talk about
being first instead of god um
and being is the totality of experience
that we're going to define that
it that way for the purposes of this
discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature
being is what you experience as a
conscious creature it includes all your
emotions all your motivations all your
subjective experience
as well as everything that's objective
okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered
it's a useful
move of faith to act
as if you love being and if you love
something then you want the best in it
to flourish
and so maybe you decide deep in your
soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an
end that makes everything that's good
better that that's the best way to live
to make everything that's good better
and maybe to restrict the development of
everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world in so far as you're
able to do that
and so i think that's an expression of
love is that because when you love
something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being i
think is care
and so so that's one element of god is
love
god being analogous in some way to being
now we could look at god more
classically as the creator of being
if you assume being is good well it's
not much of a leap to assume the creator
of being is good and
maybe you adopt an attitude towards the
creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to
existence and maybe that's the most
effective means of having existence open
its heart to you
so for example you know if you love
other people
you want the best for them you want the
best in you to serve the best in them if
you love them and you trust them
courageously
so you open yourself up to them i don't
think it's unreasonable to assume that
that's how you elicit the best from them
the best that can be elicited
you're going to get hurt sometimes and
betrayed but that's going to happen no
matter what
approach you take i think that's the
most effective approach
and that is perhaps the most effective
approach to existence
per se to approach it with love and
courage
and and so that's
how that looks to me is it a feeling
like loving a person
yes i think it is i think it is a
feeling like loving a person it's
it's the generalization of that care
that you would have for
a child your child your your brother
your sister
a family member it's the generalization
of that to the broader
domain of of existence to broader domain
of domains of existence and
i think that's a skill in some sense
right i mean if you're
good at loving and caring for your
family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that's very
difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable it
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that
and so you see that when you have a job
or you
and you encounter a boss who takes you
under his or her wing and helps develop
you
or you find a teacher who's particularly
inspiring or you work for an
entrepreneur who's inspiring and who
also opens doors for you
um they're acting with love as far as
i'm concerned they want
the best in them to serve the best in
you and that's very very motivating for
everyone and
that's the proper basis of our social
relationships not
power for god's sake so
can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a
sophisticated question i don't know the
answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of
empathy and agreeableness it's a
different dimension than responsibility
which is more part of conscientiousness
than sort of a cold virtue
i don't know if it balances out the
crushing responsibility but i think it's
the
emotional analog to the crushing
responsibility
right so maybe there's love and duty and
they run parallel in
in if you're an ethical person that's
not all there is to ethics but you know
love and duty they're they're important
and and
maybe they're better together than they
would be as independent
entities so
okay
hi dr peterson i'm a 25 year old female
i think i'm afraid of intimacy and
closeness
the thought of a man taking care of me
and having to cede some of my control to
create room for that
scares me i want to try and be in a
romantic relationship
but i don't know how to allow it what
advice do you have okay well let's take
your questions apart first of all
i think i am afraid of intimacy
and closeness okay fair enough and and
i the first thing i would tell you is
that does not make you unique
and i'm not saying that in a manner
that's designed to be condescending or
insulting i'm just saying that
well that's a very common fear you're
not alone you may think you're alone in
that but you definitely aren't and it's
also a justified fear i mean if you
allow someone to be close to you
then you open yourself up to them and
they can hurt and betray you
so of course there's reason to be afraid
so so what do you do about that
well there's reason to be afraid of lack
of intimacy and distance you want to be
alone for the rest of your life
that's a frightening thought in all
likelihood it's not that easy to get
through life on your own
you know it's lonesome and difficult and
if if you're in trouble
you don't have someone to help you out
and you don't have someone to help when
they're in trouble and you don't have
anyone to share your triumphs with and
all of that so that's not good so you
might be afraid of intimacy but you
should be at least
as afraid of its lack and so maybe those
fears can balance
you know you say well i'm afraid of
intimacy so i won't go there
well you're not afraid enough of being
alone and so you've got to bring that up
it's like yeah well i don't want to be
alone for the rest of my life assuming
you don't
it seems like you don't because you said
um
i want to try to be in a romantic
relationship so you want this
and it does look like fear is inhibiting
you to some degree because
you're 25 and it sounds from the tone of
your question that you haven't been in a
relationship before so it could easily
be fear that's stopping you so
let's talk about trust for a second
you might say well why should i trust
when i could get hurt and that's a good
question
you you trust when you're naive because
you don't know you can get hurt
and that's not ethical that's not moral
it's not laudable it's just
naivety once you know you can be hurt
you trust
as a courageous decision knowing that if
you trust someone you can bring out the
best in them and knowing that if you
don't you'll never see it
so it's a calculated risk and it's an
intelligent calculated risk designed
to move you and the other person to to
the best so you you can tell yourself
that i'm going to take a risk
i might get hurt but i'm going to take a
risk knowing it's a risk it's a
reasonable risk
don't be a fool but it's a reasonable
risk um
and remember that you have some reason
to be afraid of intimacy and closeness
but
you know you should also see both of
those as
um positives on your side to be intimate
with someone means that you can share
your thoughts with them and think things
through with them
and you can share your triumphs and your
disappointments and all of that you
broaden out your life you broaden out
your ability to solve problems
you increase the probability all things
considered that you're going to remain
sane because
two people who are communicating are
generally saner than one person who is
only thinking
by themselves so
so you don't want to deprive yourself of
that even though it's somewhat dangerous
to be hooked up with someone
um the thought of a man taking care of
me and having to cede some of my control
to create room for that scares me well
you've got to think about how you've
posed those questions
seed some of your control well are you
sure that's what a relationship is about
are you sure it's about
seeding control i mean because there's
an idea there that the relationship is
going to be based on power it's
well more you you you
end up with someone and you negotiate
with them
and so you know where do you want to
live what career do you want to have
where do you want to be educated how
many children do you want to have
well you don't know not really you have
your opinions and maybe you think i'm
going to enforce those i want that
control but
maybe you think instead well wouldn't it
be good to have the opportunity to
discuss all those options with someone
reasonable and
come to a joint conclusion about what
would be best for both of you moving
forward
maybe you could have your cake and eat
it too it's not seeding control
and i would say don't seed control like
you know if there are things in your
life that you absolutely need then you
want to negotiate for those
but the the the essence of the
relationship
should be truthful negotiation not
control and power and so
you may be afraid because you have
misapprehension about what an optimal
relationship a reasonable relationship
would be
um the thought of a man taking care of
me
well what do you mean by that exactly i
mean
do you do you feel that it's that you're
going to be infantilized because someone
is taking care of you that they're going
to want
but they're going to want to um decide
what's best for you
well again there's a power assumption
lurking at the bottom of that that may
not be helpful
to be taken care of means that you know
someone is going to be looking out for
you and
if they think something is good and
helpful for you are going to help you
find it and maybe help provide
that for you but you're going to do that
with them reciprocally so
you'll be taking care of each other and
that should be a positive thing on both
fronts i know that's idealistic and it's
never perfect and
there is power struggles in a
relationship but that doesn't mean that
the power dynamic is the basis for the
relationship it sounds to me like you're
afraid of being
dominated and so you
you need to i i would say one thing that
you should really
strive to do when you enter a romantic
relationship is
not to avoid conflict not to pretend
that you're something other than you are
because then you won't seed control and
you won't fall prey to a
pathological power dynamic that often
happens when people hide themselves
because they don't trust
and then they don't get what they want
because how could they they've never
expressed it
you know and and then the other person
dominates them because they've never
expressed any of their own desires
well don't do that you know confer with
yourself
very useful marker for that is
resentment you know if you're
in a relationship with someone and you
feel resentment climbing up on you
that's an indication of one of two
things you're either immature
and unwilling to make the sacrifices
necessary for the relationship or to
negotiate fairly within the relationship
and then you should mature out of that
as fast as you possibly can and maybe
you can do that through dialogue with
your partner
or the resentment might mean that you
are in fact being taken advantage of and
that you have something to say
so don't let if resentment pops up find
out whether you're immature or being
oppressed and if it's the latter then
you have something to say to enter into
a negotiation
and the negotiation should be that you
both get
something better than either of you
would have had if you were separate
now sometimes it's a zero-sum game and
only one person can win the negotiation
but
that's that's sub-optimal and it
certainly isn't the typical pattern for
a good negotiation
so i want to try and be in a romantic
relationship but i don't know how to
allow it
well the next thing i would say is well
one step at a time
you don't have to do this any faster
than you want to
so slow it down you know so
how would a generic relationship start
well maybe you meet online well what do
you do first you
email each other excuse me if i'm out of
touch
you email each other you know when you
talk about trivial things to begin with
just to see if the other person can even
talk and then
you know you start sharing something and
when you do that you see if the other
person shares something of about
equivalent emotional significance and
then
maybe you share something deeper and see
if they do the same in return and
you test each other out in writing maybe
you exchange photographs and
you see if you're curious and interested
and if you are well then maybe you meet
for coffee in the middle of the
afternoon in a well-lit
location where there's lots of other
people around and you check the person
out and you have a conversation
and you see if you like them and if
there's some attraction and if there's
some curiosity and
maybe you meet for coffee three times
because you're not in a hurry
you know and then maybe you go to a
movie
and you see if you decide which movie or
if he decides which movie
and whether that can be negotiated about
and whether you respond the same way and
whether you have anything
to talk about afterwards and maybe
that's all you do maybe you go to a
movie five
times like you don't have to do this any
faster than necessary
and so if you're afraid don't bite off
more than you can chew you can
adjust the rate at which the
relationship progresses and i would say
and i would say that to all
the women who are listening it's like
slow the hell down
there you think that if you don't allow
the relationship to proceed
sexually say at a very rapid rate you're
going to lose the interest of the guy if
that's the case then lose it because
it's not worth it
if he has any sense at all if you slow
things down
and there's anything more there than
just mere physical
lust let's say narrow-minded impulsive
physical lust
which is nothing to sneer at by the way
but is hardly the basis for a good
relationship
if he can't tolerate it's slowing down
well then he's not that interested in
you or
he's immature or so don't worry about
that slow it down
it's it's to everyone's advantage to
slow it down
so slow it down until you're not afraid
that's part of learning to negotiate
with yourself so get the hell out there
and get in the romantic relationship try
them out
but don't do them quickly and make sure
that you keep your head about you and
that you don't you know
that you don't allow your cowardice
essentially to interfere with your
ability to express what you want
and you want to question your
presupposition that the relationship is
necessarily going to be predicated on
something like
power and control because that's not a
good relationship
that isn't how relationships should
function they're pathological when
that's what they're about and you should
be afraid of them if that's what they're
about
so get out there and learn how to do it
but do it slow
play a bit practice a bit but get at it
because you're 25 you know it's time to
get
moving you'll be 30 a lot faster than
you think
so get at it dr peterson i'm a recent
father
my daughter is one months old and
sometimes i find it hard to deal with my
daughter i feel a lot of frustration
when she spent hours crying and i don't
know what to do since you can't reason
with a baby
is it okay not to feel love to my baby
during these episodes of frustration
am i a bad father for feeling this way
um
look everyone is upset
frustrated and stressed by
a crying baby i mean that's what the
crying is
for like it's there isn't anything
that's more upsetting than a baby who
won't stop crying well for obvious
reasons right because if you didn't care
whether the baby cried well then
you wouldn't respond to its distress so
don't worry about that
it's like you know one of the things
i've often recommended to my
clients who are driven to distraction by
a baby
maybe a colicky baby you know won't quit
crying is put some ear plugs in now
you can have a baby monitor watch the
baby you know
and i'm not saying go deaf and hide in
another room so you
if something terrible happens to your
baby you don't know it but you don't
have to torture yourself to death
and some ear plugs if the baby's crying
all the time can bring the level of
stress
down for you and your wife without
interfering with anything so think about
that if the baby's crying a lot
babies shouldn't cry constantly day
after day hour after hour if
you should if that's happening if your
baby is crying
this is a guess it's not medical advice
i could be wrong but it's like a
parameter you know
if your baby is crying more than three
hours a day
especially continually and it's probably
much less than that but
um you know you should you should
probably think
about talking to a doctor about that and
see if there's some gastrointestinal
problem
one of the things you might check is and
see is what your wife is eating if she's
breastfeeding because infants can
respond quite dramatically
with intestinal upset to the components
of breast milk and
cruciferous vegetables for example can
be
particularly toxic in that regard so
that's something to check out
um you could experiment with the baby
with different
you know have your wife eat different
foods
um when she's breastfeeding but earplugs
can really be helpful
sometimes you find it hard to deal with
your crying daughter well she's only a
month old well you don't even know her
you know when when i had kids my wife of
course had
had nine months in some sense to get
accustomed to the idea of the baby
because she
had had the pregnancy and in some sense
she was already in a relationship but
my sense was who the hell is this you
know and i mean
it was a baby and it was my baby and so
it was a particular baby but
i didn't have any particular
relationship with that
person to begin with and something you
have to learn you've only had a month
you don't know this person you got to
get to know a baby even when they're
little
you have to spend time with them you
have to rock them you have
to play with them a little bit it's hard
when they're that young
um it's particularly hard for fathers in
my estimation
um you know it's easier for fathers when
babies become more interactive say after
nine months
so don't worry about that too much you
got to get to know this person but do
do that because it's worth it and so do
what you can to interact change
the baby's diapers and you know patter
and and
and and and look at her and and
babies like massage it's really good for
them and you can kind of get to know the
baby that way and
hold her as much as you can and rock her
and all of that but don't worry
like unless you you wouldn't be worried
about this if you were the kind of
monster that should worry about it
you know you're concerned because you
don't have always this
overwhelming sense of love it's like you
got to get to know this person
you will in all likelihood don't be
scared away from the baby because
because of this you know and it's only
the early months
i it took me like six months to really
start to
get to know the baby and and you see the
person's there already
like i have kids who are grown now and
they're who they were when they were
babies like they're way distant when
they're babies and they're not
well defined they're kind of far away in
some sense you know they're
they haven't come out into the world um
but the their core character is there
and you have to get to know them and as
you get to know them
you'll get to love them that that's what
will happen in all likelihoods don't
worry about that no you're not a bad
father and of course you're going to be
driven to distraction and frustration
by the baby's tears and maybe by the
child's misbehavior like
you have to defend yourself against that
and you can talk to your wife about this
and
you can spell each other too like if
your baby's crying a lot and there's
nothing
that you can do about it medically let's
say maybe
you know you need to go for an hour-long
walk and then come back and your wife
needs to go for an hour-long walk so
that you can get away from the crying
because it can drive you to
bloody distraction and it's not good to
be pushed beyond your capacity for
tolerance
but i don't see any reason for you to be
concerned you have a one month old
daughter you're
christ you're still so sleep deprived
you know likelihood you don't know which
way is up
um the first year is very intense and
although
extremely interesting and compelling
because of all the transformations it's
quite
challenging and so just hang in there
you'll
you'll do fine um
massage you know babies like touch they
like skin-to-skin contact that's another
thing you can do is put the baby on your
chest you know
with without any the baby can have a
diaper on obviously but
skin-to-skin contact babies like that
they like to be touched they like to be
patted
get to know the baby don't be afraid and
like i said earplugs can really help you
can still hear the baby crying it just
won't drive you out of your skull
and what good is that if you're all
frazzled and stressed the baby will pick
that up too so
yeah yep good luck
you know you'll you'll do fine i suspect
how did i balance marriage fatherhood
and a demanding career well
um i stopped wasting time
that helped a lot i stopped drinking i
stopped going to bars
i really didn't spend a lot of time with
my friends when i had young kids in
particular
i had friends and i i saw them you know
with some degree of regularity but
where i cut corners was more with social
life outside my family so i spent a lot
of time with my wife and i spent a lot
of time with my kids
and i spent a lot of time on my career
and so you have to make choices
and i think those are reasonable choices
i'm not displeased with them don't
abandon your friendships but
um but you can certainly look at where
you're wasting time and just
stop doing things that you know to be a
waste of time
so and i did and so i had enough room
for my marriage and i had enough room
for my kids and i had enough room for my
career
and you know sort of a multi-dimensional
career and i was always a challenge to
me too to see how efficient i could get
and you can also and i've really
recommended this for
relatively higher income dual income
couples
who are trying to pursue dual careers
kids and marriage you can outsource you
know
hire hire a cleaning lady if you can
afford it um
buy restaurant food if you can afford it
etc
no you can outsource get you can have
someone do your laundry
then you can concentrate on your
marriage and your kids i know that that
you know is only an avenue available to
people who have relatively high incomes
but people who have dual incomes have
relatively high incomes and so
outsource what's unnecessary so that you
can concentrate on what's necessary i
mean i didn't do that when
i was beginning my career because when i
lived in the united states when i was in
my late 20s and starting my family we
had one income
you'd think a harvard beginning
professor makes a lot of money and i
suppose
that's true in some absolute sense but
relatively speaking
you know we didn't have enough money to
buy magazines we we all our money went
for
for housing cost and and the basic
necessities of living i had a car that
was 20 years old
25 years old i think it was old it was a
bloody thing the doors fell apart
on the person i sold it to you know like
six months down the road they knew it
was a wreck at that point but
we drove that thing right into the
ground so i know that's not necessarily
possible for everyone at the beginning
of their career but if you have two
incomes you can manage it
um i
concentrated on my marriage and making
time for it
i concentrated on spending time with my
kids consciously
and i concentrated on developing my
career those were the three elements of
my life and i had some time left over
for creative pursuits and
and and for friends but most of it was a
matter of getting rid of
time wastes of any sort you know and i
just
pushed that out of my life you know day
after day until i wasn't wasting any
time
or virtually no time and you know i've
asked my undergraduates frequently how
much time they waste per day and
general estimates are like six to eight
hours of time they regard
themselves as wasting like that's a
whole career right there
right so if you just stop wasting time
you can do a tremendous amount
especially if you also try to maximize
efficiency
and i always found that incredibly
motivating you know i'm a motivating
game how much can i do in the least
amount of time possible
that was that's fun to try to do that as
far as i'm concerned
i know may you know that's maybe
undoubtedly a temperamental thing
but but if you're built if you're wired
that way that's a great
meta strategy become efficient i always
ask my graduate students when they were
designing experiments they'd come with a
proposal
i'd say to them you know is there any
way you could do this 10 times
faster what would you have to cut what
would you have to change to do this 10
times faster
and you can learn to do that i also
learned to
force the task to fit the time you know
there's this dictum
work expands to fill the time allowed
for its completion
well there's a corollary to that which
is
work becomes more efficient in
proportion
to the restrictions of time placed upon
it
so if you say well this could take me
two weeks but
i'm going to do the best job i could in
one day
you'd be amazed you can get 90 of the
way or 95
of the way or sometimes even farther in
that day
so that's another way of becoming
efficient you know if you only have 10
minutes to do something that
should maybe take you two hours maybe
you can figure out how to do it in 10
minutes
you can get dreadfully efficient so
that's very much worthwhile in my
estimation if you want to do a lot of
things what what else are you going to
do
you know rather than become efficient if
you want to do many things
you don't have much choice but it i
found it extremely entertaining to try
to do that
and when i was healthy i could do a
tremendous amount in a very short period
of time
i'm very frustrated that that's not so
much the case now although perhaps it's
coming back to some degree
i have recently found a passion in
studying psychology
i can relate to that what book should i
read to expand my interest
anything written by the great clinicians
assuming that you're
us interested in clinical psychology i
presume that because when people think
about psychology they generally don't
think about research psychology
which is a different endeavor they
usually think about clinical psychology
all the great clinicians carl rogers
abraham maslow
sigmund freud carl jung um
who else
i'm it's silly i i i guess i'm running
out of steam here so
let me just look them up for a minute
i was going to try to help
eric erickson yes eric erickson jean
piaget great developmental psychologist
um that's a good start more
[Music]
practically go to my website under
books jordanbpeterson.com books
recommended books there's a whole list
of books that were extremely influential
to me
some of them were more research oriented
like jeffrey gray's treatise on the
neuropsychology of anxiety
and there's a great work on higher
cortical functions in man by
alexander lurie and some other brain
function books there as well you can go
read all those books that'll
inform you and and you know when you
read those
people you'll find out what they read
and you can go read them too so that's a
good start so
do that that'll that'll keep you going
for a good length of time
um do you have any interest in the new
biblical lecture series
yes i have much interest in that
i have started reading exodus i would
love to do a lecture on a lecture series
on exodus i'm thinking
hoping praying that i can do that in the
fall
of this year if kovid vanishes if the
theaters open up so i could rent a
theater again
i'd like to do a dozen lectures on
exodus in october and november
and uh it's a great story exodus it's
it's you know the story of tyranny
the collapse of tyranny into an
interregnum period of chaos
and the promised land that's the story
of human adaptation
go from a terrible place that is full of
restrictions you have to blow it apart
because it's too restrictive and
tyrannical but you don't immediately go
to a better place you go to a worse
place
you cross the sea where you could drown
you
are in the desert for 40 years and then
you struggle back towards a new state of
equilibrium it's psychological
uh it's the the narrative of
psychological transformation upward
that's a political narrative it's an
economic narrative it's a battle between
the forces of
water and the forces of stone water
representing chaos that's moses
and stone representing tyranny it's
brilliant and
deep and profound and i would love to do
a lecture series on exodus if i had the
intellectual wherewithal
and and so it's one of my great hopes
that i
would be able to do that so that's my
plan and
you know if i'm healthy enough i'll try
it and see if i can manage it
um god willing and all that so
what are your thoughts on superheroes
well they're quasi-religious figures
they're
you know they're they're literary
figures symbolic figures
they're amalgams of what's admire
admirable so imagine that
we have this instinct to admire it
and it takes us over it doesn't happen
voluntarily exactly you admire someone
sort of despite your will and you tend
to admire the ideal so here's an example
i was talking to a great biologist this
week
randy thornhill dr randy thornhill who
discovered the role of symmetry
bilateral symmetry in sexual
attractiveness while he
showed for example or or people who were
influenced by his research showed that
even babies will look longer at a
symmetrical face
and symmetrical face is more attractive
or an average face
is more attractive and an average
symmetrical face is even more attractive
newborn babies even our very young
babies will look much longer at an
attractive face
than a non-attractive face and that's
because they
are primed to admire the ideal that they
need to strive to become
that's the instinct for admiration it's
part of the fundamental religious
instinct which is the instinct to admire
the admirable as such
in some sense to feel awe in the
presence of what's great and to wish
to develop towards that spontaneously
um and so well superheroes
in some sense you really wouldn't need
superheroes in a culture that had a
fully functioning
religious structure because the
religious structure would fill in the
superhero gap
but since the death of god so to speak
well we need superheroes because that's
part of the way that we rebuild our gods
and so you take a given superhero and
he's an amalgam of some admirable traits
you know he might have some flaws too
just to make it more interesting or
sometimes because
an admirable trait comes along with a
flaw and that
that that's part of the complexity of
the world but the superhero is
not a normal person he's a super person
obviously and super means super ordinate
it means above and so
you know if you took three people and
took the best from each of them and made
them into one person they would be a
sort of superhero
and so you know there's a fictional
element because the powers are expanded
but
that's also a way of exploring the fact
that with admirable qualities comes an
increment in power
so um that's perfectly fine and so
superhero the reason our culture is so
enthralled by superheroes is because
we're nowhere near religious enough
obviously that's the reason it's the
same way same reason we're in trans
especially the engineering types who
tend much less to be
uh classically religious because of
their thing-like orientation rather than
their people orientation they get all
their religion through
science fiction they don't even notice
that it's happening but it doesn't
matter it's happening
if you're interested in that sort of
thing you could read the hero with a
thousand faces by joseph campbell
that's a great in illus a great
representation of the emergence of
heroic themes in literature
across cultures literature and religious
religious thinking
or you could read the origins and
history of consciousness by
eric neumann n-e-u-m-a-n-n
eric is e-r-i-c-h eric neumann the
origins and history of consciousness
both of those books i think
are on my list of recommended books on
my website
i'm not sure about the hero with a
thousand faces it should be there if it
isn't because it's a great book
um in any case superheroes are quasi
divinities and
i mean obviously look at thor and and
i mean marvel comics has divinities in
its superhero pantheon
and they fit in perfectly because what's
the difference between iron man
and thor you know immortality i suppose
although thor's immortality can't be
absolute or he wouldn't be interesting
because you couldn't kill him and you're
not interesting unless you can die
so so you know superheroes evoke the
the the evoke admiration and the desire
to emulate
and and you know the superheroes are
always battling
they're always good against evil and so
the landscape that superheroes
inhabit which is good and evil against
the background of chaos and order is the
mythological or the religious landscape
so it's it's all religion just
repackaged so that people don't notice
because they have to be religious if
they notice they criticize the religion
and then they can't be religious and so
and then they can't orient themselves so
it sneaks up on us and
takes us over in forms that we don't
tend to notice consciously are religious
but
nonetheless that is what they are so and
they're so
successful today because well like i
said
our culture is is had the slats kicked
out from underneath it
so it it doesn't have a traditionally
functioning
religious substructure and it has to
it has to um partly what i've been
writing about recently is the
contamination of political
belief with religious belief because
religious belief isn't put in its proper
place
and then politics becomes religion and
then that's a bloody catastrophe
literally so yeah
so that's why have you done any more
reading about islam
not in the last two years i haven't done
much reading at all although i've been
reading a lot i suppose in preparation
for these podcasts that i've been doing
but other than that
i haven't really been able to read so
i've bought lots of books about islam
and i have read a fair number of them
previously
are you planning to have a debate with a
muslim on my podcast
no but i am i do have two muslim
scholars scheduled for the next month
and a half one more liberal
um who wrote a book called reopening
muslim minds
and another hamza youssef who's more
conservative who's been recommended to
me by
well the liberal more liberal author of
this book was one but oh by many many
people on
youtube i mean i've been wanting to do
this for a long time but
i didn't believe that i had the
intellectual wherewithal to manage it
it's not going to be a debate though
because what the hell do i know about
islam
you know i mean i can talk to whoever
i'm talking to like an ignorant
westerner
and that's what i'll do and and i'll put
up whatever objections
a said ignorant westerner might have and
questions but mostly what i want to do
is
listen and ask questions i don't have
anything to debate because
i just i don't know the culture well
enough to debate it
i mean i can i can put forward my
objections to what i see
as certain attributes that appear to be
associated with the culture
like the fact that women's rights
construed from a western perspective
tend to be
um what less than manifest let's say
in countries that are islamic so i'd
like to
talk about that for example so and
especially given that there is
overwhelming empirical evidence that
rights granted to women is one of the
best predictors of economic well-being
you know so i don't know how islamic
fundamentalist cultures
deal with that particular fact they
don't tend to score all that well in
terms of economic freedom or
productivity as well
so you know those are incendiary claims
but
those are the sorts of things i'm going
to say perfectly willing to be
revealed as wrong but you know the best
i'm going to be able to do because i'm
not that
informed it's a very complex culture
it's not easy to
unpack and it's also not a culture that
has really unpacked itself right it's
still
in many ways a functioning religious
society
it hasn't subjected itself to analytical
self-criticism and so
that makes it very difficult to
understand philosophically
from the outside so anyways you can see
how this discussion might go but i'm
very much looking forward to it and i
hope it's
you know i've had this vision visions
literally visions of
everyone coming to the table so to speak
you know and we need to bring everybody
to the great
banquet table of the world and hopefully
these dialogues will be part of that
some
small part of that and so i'm really
looking forward to it and i hope i
conduct it well i
have lots of muslim
readers and viewers and and listeners
and
i don't want to alienate them casually
or purposefully for that matter i want
to say what i have to say and stick as
close to the truth as i can possibly
manage
but i want to engage in a genuine
dialogue because we need to engage in a
genuine dialogue because the alternative
to that is war
so or if not war failure to cooperate
and that would be stupid because
you'd we do a lot better if we all
cooperated obviously
so so anyways i have two people coming
on and hopefully that'll you know
lead to something else that's the that's
the hope
and so i'll talk to these two people
within the next month
and release those talks within the next
two months
so that's the upshot
for that what is the difference between
spirituality
faith and religion well that's not a
very well posed question i don't i don't
mean that
uh to be critical i'm going to
restructure the question
you can think about two elements of
religious
uh of religious phenomenology
phenomena that are associated with the
religious world
there's a spiritual element that's
less constrained by belief and more a
consequence of say emotion
and motivation and aesthetic experience
and all of that unbounded in some way by
explicit dogma so there's a dogmatic
element and
a spiritual element and that would
correspond roughly speaking to the
to the to belief versus exploration
uh in a more general cognitive sense
roughly
um but both are necessary
right because for all its flaws
collective adherence to a dogma that's
there's no distinction between that and
peace
because peace reigns when people accept
unquestioningly
a sufficient number of presuppositions
to guarantee
cooperation so you don't get away
without dogma you might say you're
anti-dogmatics like
yeah in some ways possibly now and then
and some people more than others but
most of the time when you ask a question
you you hold a thousand things constant
and allow one thing to vary
and so the constancy is the dogma and
the variation is the
questioning there's a spiritual element
that's
associated with experience with awe with
wonder
with questions about the meaning of life
with the feeling of love the feeling of
devotion the feeling of duty the desire
to admire
the aesthetic sense that that a visit to
a cathedral might produce or
or gospel music or or or music in
general for that matter which has a
pronounced
religious element spiritual element and
lots of people
describe themselves as spiritual but not
religious which means
that well they haven't been able to
apply
systematic philosophical reasoning to
the where's and why's of their
experience
so now if if a belief system becomes
entirely dogmatic it tends to rigidify
and ossify and become tyrannical so
that's not good
but if it's only spiritual like the new
age movement let's say
then it's everything and nothing at the
same time everything goes everything is
permitted
all is equal everything falls under the
same umbrella
it's so inclusive and so non-structured
that
it really degenerates into nothing at
all so there always has to be a balance
between
structure and openness to change and
structure is dogma and openness to
changes
exploration and both of them have a
religious element
so and then you also included faith
well i'm not going to talk about that
because i'm i'm out of brainpower for
the day
so we'll just stick with spirit versus
dogma for the answer to that question
for now and that's pretty much
all i can manage for the day thank you
very much for submitting your questions
and for
persevering this far into this video if
you have in fact done that and i hope
that you found the questions interesting
and the answers
useful and thank you for your attention
and
and uh i hope that
well you're welcome to tune in to
another lecture whenever you feel the
inclination to do so
bye bye